um but the reality is there
are some real conspiracies um dating
back to the atomic bomb and this i get
into in the book
the the development of the atomic bomb
was one of the biggest conspiracies in
history
uh a hundred thousand people were
involved and only about 12
actually knew what they were doing the
rest of them were doing something they
had no idea what they were even fake
cities made full of all of these
engineers who had no idea what they were
actually working on
um cities that then vanished afterwards
um there were
you know uh efforts to take the word
nuclear
out of all newspapers they even took it
out of
cartoons even the buck rogers comic book
was censored
um because they wanted to take the words
nuclear and radiate
uh uh uh anything anything having to do
with nuclear weapons
out of it so that people wouldn't even
think in that realm
so there have been massive conspiracies
in history
and looking at the ufo world there's no
question
that the roswell investigation and what
happened afterwards
was covered up there was a cover-up um
and so that's what
it feeds this whole thing um if they had
been more open about it earlier perhaps
less people
would believe in ufos that's the
interesting thing
um is is hiding it is what's made it
into the sort of crazy world it is
yeah and it's it's such a fun subject
such a fun thing to get freaked out
about yeah
i mean listen you know i think it's
coming out now that
pretty clearly pilots have seen things
that we still don't understand
uh i think it's pretty clear that there
are is in the possession of the air
force
or bigelow some objects that we still
don't understand
um and so you know we'll see what
happens
yeah the guy the guy who was in the u.s
air force in uh
san diego captain fravor i believe his
name was
who shows that he which originally came
out that video
of his radar tracking that object
that guy was you can hear that guy's
voice on the video he's freaked out
oh yeah this guy's a rock solid military
man i mean he's not a conspiracy
theorist this guy has no interest in
ufos or aliens
no there's absolutely there's absolutely
been things that radar operators navy
pilots have seen
that cannot be explained yet whether
they are some sort of weird technology
that
somebody has figured out here um that we
can't conceptualize yet okay that's a
possibility
but you can't throw out the
extraterrestrial thing
and that's part of the whole point of my
book 37th parallel is that
20 years ago maybe even 10 years ago you
could throw it out
because we didn't know that there were
so many earth-like planets out there
we didn't know that some of these
planets aren't really that far away
and we used to think that it was
impossible to traverse
these vast distances because we didn't
have the technology but that's
actually changing we're at a point right
now where we
find new planets every day that could
support
life right and we also are at a point
where our technology has advanced to the
point
where getting to one-fifth the speed of
light is not technically impossible
anymore
one-fifth the speed of light you can use
solar sails to get there
um it's been theorized that you know
that you could
and there's something called the star
shot program where they're going to make
postcard size
probes attached to massive solar sails
that you could actually get these things
up to one-fifth the speed of light
if that's the case you can get to the
next earth-like planet in about 20 to 40
years and that's not that long
so the idea that these these these vast
regions of space are just
too far it's not really true anymore um
and so the reasons to not believe in
ufos has definitely changed
have you ever heard of a guy named
robert hastings i've heard the name yeah
yeah he wrote that book ufos and nukes
yeah i have that book uh
fascinating so yes a lot of ufo fighting
but that could be evidence of
of russians as well you know yeah that's
that's the scary thing that's what the
government's everybody's freaked out
about is that the
this isn't some extraterrestrial thing
this could be china or russia
right and there's a great book i just
lost the name of it this woman wrote
what was it called um
shoot about about roswell and what her
belief what roswell was
was actually stalin had sent over a uh a
fake ufo
to try and scare the midwest um it was a
brilliant book i can't remember what it
was
i think it was called area 51 was that
what it was um
but yeah i mean there's lots of
different theories that don't involve
extraterrestrials that could explain it
as well
but because of the policy of keeping it
as secret as possible
or outsourcing it to robert bigelow who
keeps it as secret as possible
um it makes it very hard for anyone to
know what's really going on
so did bigelow um
did bigelow do the initial
archaeological dig
in roswell near area 51 so chuck
zukowski was involved in that it was
actually a television show that
did the original one that i wrote about
in my book but what happened was
chuck found something he found a weird
piece of metal
during this archaeological dig and he
basically went online and said is there
anyone out there who can help me analyze
this piece of metal
and he was uh uh approached by bigelow's
people
they said yeah we'll analyze it this is
this is what we do so he sent them the
medal
and then they never sent it back to them
so he actually ends up going and trying
to get it back
it's a really interesting story but um
bigelow's people
were involved at the time with basically
investigating any
ufo sighting or anything that could have
any legitimate
um connection to ufos or roswell or
something like that
he was well funded his his team had you
know
had had the funds real laboratories and
um and they would go out and and
research this stuff
um roswell has been investigated
numerous numerous times many many times
what happened at roswell is still
completely you know um masked in mystery
i guess
something was found there whatever that
thing was that was found
still exists um but nobody uh knows what
it is
the reason i have trouble with the
cow mutilations especially relating to
skinwalker ranch like yeah it's super
weird there's no blood there's these
surgical incisions
um but there's no hard evidence really
of anything ever happening there
no there's no evidence so skin walker
ranch and
cadmium they're two separate things but
take the cattle mutilations
i mean cattle mutilations are a weird
phenomenon it's gone on for a very long
time
um there's no good theory of what they
are um the fbi
at first thought it was a uh cult
rituals
then they thought it was a motorcycle
gang that was doing this for some reason
as some sort of
ritual to join the motorcycle gang but
in the end they concluded um that
that we don't have any evidence of
either of those things um so
nobody really knows what that is why it
would be related to ufos i could not
tell you
the only reason that people related to
ufos is a lot of times
people see lights in the sky or hear
weird noises
or or things like that if you talk to
these ranchers
um so that's the connection but there's
no evidence that a ufo would have any
reason to do that
um so yes that's just one of the weird
phenomenon that
seems to happen along the 37 parallel
skinwalker ranch was this weird crazy
ranch in utah
where um lots of things were seen
anecdotally
um weird you know changes in
time and monsters appearing mutilated
cattle
and then bigelow bought it big of those
people actually
bought skinwalker ranch set up a bunch
of scientists to work there for years
and and put down what they saw but again
no evidence ever came out
that doesn't mean there isn't evidence
um and so
the question is what's going on at
bigelow you know he's got lots and lots
of files
um which he's never spoken about um
never shown to anyone
um and he's moved into a legitimate you
know aeronautics business um
which you know makes pieces for your
national space station
and just sort of brushes over that whole
ufo thing
um which he was involved with for many
many years so the question becomes
are there files there is there info
there are there
objects there um what does he have and
uh
we don't have the answer to that what is
the most unexplainable or questionable
thing to you
about your book about everything that
you studied and everyone you talked to
making the third writing the 37th
parallel so i think
number one and this has come out
recently i had seen files
talking about unexplained um
materials and objects um that were not
old files
so i knew that at this point in time
there are still
things that the air force has that they
can't figure out what they are
so i knew that before this recent
release so i think that was the number
one thing that spurred me on
um was the idea that people at very high
levels in the air force
have you know are talking about
internally materials
uh that they can't understand um and
that's weird because if these were
things found in the 50s
by now we should know what they are you
know our technology has advanced to the
point
that we should be ahead of anything that
could have been made in the 50s um
so that means it must not be by us um
that um the bigelow stuff is very
intriguing to me
um but in general it's just sort of
fascinating to me i loved close
encounters of the movie
and and so i always kind of wanted to
write something in that realm
um so i'm on the fence you know i'm not
you know
someone who's just a true ufo believer i
believe you know
uh in everything i i am a believer
though that there
is evidence that has not come to light
and there's information
that still hasn't been explained and so
i guess that's where i land on this i
would love to see
everything that the air force has on
this subject i would love to
know you know all of their sort of
details about these objects and i would
love to know what bigelow has
you know in his own possession um so
those are the things that are most
intriguing to me
but um but yeah i guess that's it so
what else are you working on do you have
any
any uh projects that are coming up in
the near future
or yeah presently recently i i wrote a
serialized novel for the boston globe
which appeared one chapter a day for 20
days
it was a thriller like a da vinci code
style thriller called the mechanic
which ended up being very popular in the
region and
i sold it to spielberg and i'm writing
the movie now so i'm writing the
screenplay
and uh and it's going to be a big book
next fall
and then a sequel the following fall so
that's kind of the main project so it's
like a da vinci code style
thriller about a mystery going all the
way back to the american revolution
it's really cool stuff based in real
facts and and i think you'll like it a
lot
i